YURI GRINSHTEYN: Last time, we
created a Kubernetes cluster
and set up the new Stackdriver
monitoring and logging on it.
Today, we're going
to set up alerting
to let us know if there are
any issues with our application
running on that cluster.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What can we do to
get an early heads up
that something is going wrong?
Well, the first thing
to do is to figure out
what our service level
indicators, or SLIs,
should be, and then
have Stackdriver
let us know if and when our
application may be in danger
of violating the Service
Level Objectives, or SLOs,
we'll define.
You may be thinking-- wait, SLI?
What's that?
Well, an SLI is the metric
we'll measure and use
as a proxy for user happiness.
For our service running
on our GKE cluster,
we're primarily going to
care about two things--
latency and availability.
We'll want to know if
and when either of those
drops below our
desired thresholds.
But how?
The great news is that
Stackdriver gives us
an easy way to do what we
want with alerting policies.
Let's set one up for
availability now.
But first, what should
we use as our SLI?
The first option is
pretty straightforward.
We simply have the
application output
all errors to standard
out or standard
error, which will then show
up in Stackdriver logging
automatically.
We can then configure
log-based metrics
from those that'll tell us
how many errors or failures
we're seeing, and we
can use that as our SLI.
Another option would be to use a
proper instrumentation approach
with something like OpenCensus.
We won't get into the
details of that library here,
but you can watch Morgan
do a great deep dive on it.
We'll post a link to
that in the description.
Our third option to
consider is Prometheus.
It's a leading open
source monitoring tool,
and the good news is
that the beta version
of Stackdriver monitoring
for Kubernetes supports it.
Just install Prometheus
into your cluster,
and you're good to go.
Export metrics in
your application,
and the Prometheus exporter
will ship them right
into the Stackdriver backend.
So those are our three options--
log metrics, OpenCensus,
and Prometheus.
No matter which
one you choose, you
will have metrics you can use
to represent availability.
Let's do that now.
We can create an alerting
policy using the GRPC completed
RPCs metric to let us know when
we get more failures than we
allocate an error budget
for, and we're done.
I should note that, while error
rate is a great service level
indicator, this alerting policy
is not a true service level
objective.
It doesn't have a
good way to represent
what percentage of
overall calls are failing,
which is what we really need.
That is provided by the service
monitoring functionality
in Stackdriver, which we'll
cover in a future video.
Now that we've got
availability covered,
let's take care of
our latency SLI.
As with availability,
there's more than one way
to measure application latency.
We can use load balancer logs,
an instrumentation library
like OpenCensus, or even logging
from the application itself.
As before, let's start by
creating an alerting policy.
We'll select an OpenCensus
latency metric as our condition
and put a response
time threshold on it.
And there we go--
we've now got our application
running in Kubernetes
and instrument for monitoring.
And Stackdriver's
going to tell us
if anything goes
wrong that impacts
latency or availability.
When something happens that
causes our availability
or latency to fall below the
thresholds we've defined,
Stackdriver will
create an incident.
That incident can also be
used to trigger notifications
like email messages,
integrations
with other alert management
systems, or even web hook
calls to trigger remediation
actions if we want.
When the application is
restored to a healthy state
through some corrective
actions, like rolling back
a breaking change, the
incident will be resolved.
Come back next time,
when we take a deeper
look at troubleshooting latency
issues with Stackdriver Trace.
That's it for this episode.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]